we're gonna begin with one of the
biggest stars in golf quitting the pga
tour to join a rival league backed by
saudi arabia dustin johnson who has won
the masters and u.s open announced
yesterday he is playing in the new live
golf invitational series according to
britain's telegraph johnson was paid
about 125 million dollars to switch
125 wow million big ones they call that
a dump truck full of money that's a lot
of money johnson who's been on the pga
tour since 2008 says he chose what is
best for him and his family other top
players leaving the pga to play for the
new league include phil mickelson and
sergio garcia lib's first tournament is
tomorrow outside of london johnson says
he expects to play in the u.s open next
week because he is an exemption as a
recent champion that allows him to play
in the majors i'm just going to draw our
viewers attentions to comments that phil
mickelson made to a biographer and which
he since apologized for but he did is
quoted as saying the saudis are scary
mfers we know that they killed khashoggi
and have a horrible record on human
rights they execute people over there
for being gay knowing all of this why
would i consider it because it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity you did
apologize for that but the money well he
also yeah i need to have a lot of heat
for that too despite it and the live ceo
said that tiger woods would got a
similar offer to dustin johnson
nine figures
and turned it down it down
it's got a little money maybe there's
bank accounts yeah i think dustin's
doing it dustin's doing all right he's
earned uh
something like 75 million dollars fifth
highest or something like that as far as
wins on the tour i believe all right
money talks money does everything else
hard to look away for 125 million
dollars don't get me wrong agreed tiger
did